James Cameron's Avatar is the
highest-grossing film of all time and
it's not likely to lose a title soon if
ever only Cameron's previous efforts
Titanic and Star Wars Force awakens
have even come within shouting distance
of Avatar staggering nearly 2.8 billion
dollar run yet there seems to be no rush
getting the obligatory avatars he calls
into theatres last year
release dates were finally announced for
the next films and Cameron's planned
series with avatar to hitting screens on
December 18 to 2020 but if that bit of
news slipped by you it may be because
the public's appetite for avatars
continuing story may not be as ravenous
as Cameron thinks and because one
massively successful film even the most
successful ever may not necessarily
translate to a sustainable franchise he
is why we're more than a little
concerned about avatar 2 memories fade
extremely belated sequels can sometimes
work but it's a tricky proposition Blade
Runner 2049 is an illustration of how it
can go right creatively but in general
audiences are now accustomed to the
big-budget serialized storytelling of
the Star Wars and Marvel franchises
attention spans are relatively short and
fans usually have to wait there longer
than the year for the next installment
to carry the story forward in today's
movie market avatar came out almost a
decade ago and when the follow-up hits
theaters in 2020 it'll have been a full
11 years since the first films turned
everyone into repeat showings there's a
chance that all the enthusiasm and fan
fervor that drove the first film success
might not be as strong after so much
time away from Pandora climate change
the vast majority of the hype
surrounding avatar in the months leading
up to its release but more to do with
the technology involved on the actual
storyline or cast of characters avatar
was promoted as the first movie to treat
3d not as a gimmick but as a serious
storytelling tool as with Titanic before
it's it was James Cameron's
revolutionary filmmaking techniques that
had audiences so intrigued by what it
created avatar certainly delivered on
its promise of a bold new world of CGI
and an immersive 3d film experience but
upon revisiting the picture through a
more current lens the flaws of the film
storytelling come into focus more than
the Chloe's space plans and Navi
costumes for one thing it's now widely
agreed that the film is derivative even
James Cameron himself has admitted to
the central plot being an alien version
of dances with walls the film also leans
into the same white hero complex has
become so problematic and has been
accused of ripping off everything from
animated films like Fern Gully and
Pocahontas to Marvel comics time spirit
series even if none of the plagiarism
accusations levied against Cameron are
true
audiences may be more discerning now
about these kinds of troublesome tropes
and recycled plot points high
expectations even though it's not a sure
thing that sabotage you will succeed
Cameron isn't just planning to bring us
one avatar sequel he's working on four
of them with release dates slated
through 2025 these films were expected
to be shot back-to-back with a combined
the budget of 1 billion dollars which is
an enormous gamble not only from a
financial but also from a storytelling
standpoint
Cameron's silenced the doubters of his
massive ambition before of course but
he's gonna have to not only prove he's
got enough material to justify making
four full sequels that he can earn
enough return on those pictures to
compensate for the insane amount of
front-end investment considering no
weather film has ever come close to
topping avatars box-office supremacy
even the most optimistic studio
executive has to know avatar 2 might not
live up to the gains of his predecessor
one wrong move and it could spell
disaster for lighthouse Pictures and Fox
that's a lot of pressure for the
filmmaker to be under so it's a wonder
why he didn't just opt to make one
follow-up movie first and measure the
audience's interest before plunging
headfirst into such an expensive
undertaking trounced tech when avatar
first arrived in theaters it was one of
a kind sure audiences had seen 3d movies
and theaters before but none had ever
quite had the kind of majestic color
schemes and landscapes that this movie
offered since then though such visual
effects have become much more
commonplace in blockbuster films from
the superhero sphere to the world of
animated films though James Cameron has
insisted that his avatar sequels are
going to boast some similar
technological breakthroughs to keep
audience has intrigued it may be tough
for avatar to to find new ground to
break in that regard rumor has it he may
even be working on a way to deliver the
experience without the use of glasses
but will it be enough to get people to
the ticket booth it doesn't bode well
for him the audiences of throne wary of
seeing movies in 3d in recent years
ticket sales for 3d screenings have
dropped like a rock from about 20% of
ticket sales in 2010 to 14% in
20:16 even IMAX theaters have
drastically reduced their 3d slates
citing their clear preference of
consumers for 2d simply put the
groundbreaking CGI and industry-leading
3d that drove avatars must-see status in
2009 may be virtual non factors in 2020
which means avatar 2 will have to stand
on its own merits
quiet cast apart from Sigourney Weaver
the cast of Avatar was made up of
largely lesser-known actors who did a
fine enough job but haven't gone on to
top the a-list Zoe Saldana is an
exception to that rule as she's earned
prime placement and other space stories
like Star Trek and guardians of the
galaxy since then but the rest of the
cast has remained relatively unknown so
at the fact that most of the original
stars signed on for the sequels didn't
exactly blow anyone away in fact it may
be problematic that some Worthington is
coming back to lead all four films of
marine Jake Sully
since the actor has pretty much failed
to break out in any meaningful way after
his stint in the blue suit since
starring in Avatar Worthington has put
together a string of forgettable roles
including two ill-advised big-budget
reboots and a bunch of movies are very
few film goers of even heard of he's
hardly a box-office draw of course he
was even less so when the first film
came out but back then Cameron had the
benefit of being able to draw everyone
in with his magic filmmaking the biggest
new name to join the fold is Kate
Winslet and even she's been on a career
downslope lately so we'll have to see
whether sticking with actors who don't
talk among the crowd will work out in
his favor again this time around stiff
competition Disney may have a horse in
the Avatar box-office race before the
second film it's theaters not only are
they licensed purveyors of Pandora
themed merchandise but they've also
recently launched a Pandora themed world
Orlando's animal kingdom in addition
they're in the process of purchasing the
vast majority of the film and television
are sets of avatars distributer Fox
which would make them even greater
beneficiaries of the film's theoretical
success if the deal goes through as
expected
Disney may try to avoid directly
competing with the sequels until then
though the house of mouse doesn't have
to stand down against the long overdue
sequel to a one-time blockbuster that
might not even reach its intended
audience after all they're already
expecting to bring forth new Star Wars
entries through 2025 the year in which
avatar 5 is scheduled to hit
Green's and Marvel has a roadmap for
their cinematic universe lined up
through 2028 and possibly beyond this
kind of predictable competition didn't
exist during avatars box office home run
so in order for the sequels to succeed
Cameron will have to meet and possibly
even exceed the storytelling and
cinematic appeal of this well-oiled
machine franchises too far originally
only a single sequel to avatar got the
green light from the studio but then
Cameron started envisioning the story as
a trilogy but before long the creative
process seemed to get completely out of
hand speaking with variety
Cameron issue perhaps the most ominous
sign yet with regard to the sequels
quality the avatar story arc was
originally meant to be a trilogy but I
over rights and my writers over wrote as
well basically the first of the sequels
cloned itself and became two films so
now it's four films and the studio is
very happy with it they have an
opportunity to make more money but it's
also an opportunity to spend a lot more
money too so there's a clench factor and
that in a nutshell is why avatar 2 in a
sequels should raise some serious red
flags they're big budget Gamble's a
return to a world which has taken little
hold in the public imagination with a
questionable story stretched across far
more films and should be needed to tell
it but hey if Peter Jackson could
stretch the Hobbit into three
feature-length films that made a billion
apiece well what's to say James Cameron
doesn't defy all odds again as well
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love tape
you